[Musique]
bonsoir à toutes bonsoir à tous merci
d'être avec nous sur tv78 nous sommes le
mardi 10 octobre voici le programme de
ce soir la première ministre Élisabeth
borne en visite aujourd'hui à manilamo
les réquisitions du procès de l'attentat
de mananville mais aussi si les
championnats de France de BMX Freestyle
au Vélodrome national de Saint-Quentin
en yeline retrouverz en début d'émission
l'actualité à retenir aujourd'hui dans
les Yvelines en France les femmes sont
encore trop peu présentes dans la
recherche scientifique elles ne
représentent que 29 % des chercheur
alors pour briser ce plafond de verre la
Fondation L'Oréal et l'UNESCO récompens
chaque année des doctorantes ou
post-doctorantes et parmi les 35 jeunes
chercheuses primés trois sont
ivelinoises et comme chaque mardi nous
ferons également un point sur la culture
dans les Yvelines entre littérature
exposition d'art ou encore festival de
bande dessiné l'actualité est riche dans
le département et puis l'invité du 78 en
deuxème partie d'émission on reviendra
sur les ivelinoises distinguées par la
Fondation L'Oréal l'UNESCO et comme
Ophélie mintosh primé pour ses
recherches sur Mars notamment et
justement Ophélie mintosh vous êtes avec
nous en plateau bonsoir bonsoir alors
vous venez de finir votre thèse à
l'observatoire de versaill 50 en Yveline
et à l'Institut national italien
d'astrophysique et vos recherches
portent sur la planète Mars est-ce que
cette planète réunit les conditions
favorables à la vie on en parlera un peu
plus en détail en fin d'émission avec
nous également sur ce plateau un
journaliste de la rédaction de tv78
Grégory canalé bonsoir bonsoir Mathilde
vous allez nous présenter les
informations à retenir dans les ivelines
dans quelques instants c'est tout de
suite
d'ailleurs et commence ses informations
grégoryie par la première ministre qui
était en visite dans les ivelines
aujourd'hui ellisabeth borne s'est
rendue à maniléamoau elle était
accompagné de Charlotte cobel secrétaire
d'État chargé de l'enfance pour une
visite et du Collège Albert Einstein
l'établissement est engagé dans la lutte
contre le cyberhcèlement au travers du
programme px des élèves de 6e sont
formés tout au long de l'année pour
obtenir un passeport numérique la
première ministre a d'ailleurs pu
échanger avec ses jeunes le
cyberhcèlement toucherait 25 % des
collégi en France selon la Direction
Générale de l'Enseignement scolaire il y
a de semaines le gouvernement a détaillé
les contours de son plan contre le
harcèlement scolaire après le suicide du
jeune Nicolas poissi il y a du nouveau
dans le procès de l'attentat de
Magnanville la réclusion perpétuelle la
réclusion criminelle à perpétuuité avec
une peine de 22 ans de sûreté c'est ce
qui est requis contre Mohamed lbid
aberous c'est ce qui donc c'est l'homme
qui est jugé pardon par par la Cour
d'Assise spéciale de Paris pour
complicité d'assassinat au nom de l'État
islamique il est accusé d'avoir été
présent sur les lieux de l'attentat le
13 juin 2016 Jessica Schneider et
Jean-Baptiste Salvin un couple de
policiers avaient été assassiné à leur
domicile de Magnanville sous les yeux de
leur enfant alors âgé de 3 ans
l'accusation contre Mohamed lamid
aberous repose notamment sur une trace
ADN retrouvée sur le repose-poignet de
l'ordinateur portable des victimes même
si lui réfute toute présence sur place
il est le seul accusé dans ce procès
puisque le terroriste avait été abattu
dans l'assut du Raed pour libérer l' F
du couple verdict attendu demain à
poissi l'inauguration du campus PSG est
reportée elle devait avoir lieu C
automne mais elle est finalement
reprogrammée au printemps 2024 la
direction veut que toute la famille
pariss-germain soit réunie pour
l'événement le groupe professionnel
masculin a bien pris ses quartiers
depuis juillet mais l'équipe féminine et
les jeunes du centre de formation et de
préformation doivent arriver sur place
seulement en janvier après la fin de
nouveaux travaux suivront à l'horizon
2026 l'équipe de andb et les judocas du
PSG le chantier du gymnase et du dojo
sera lancé l'année prochaine et la
construction d'un stade de 3000 places
reste toujours en suspend même si un
permis de construire a été déposé et
enfin c'est officiel le vélodrome
national de Saint-Quentin en Eveline va
accueillir un nouvel événements sportifs
et c'est une première Mathilde il s'agit
des championnats de France de BMX
Freestyle qui se tiendront les 9 et 10
décembre prochain avec la présence des
meilleurs riders français en pleine
préparation olympique et des
championnats qui concernent de 10
discipline du freestyle le parc et le
flat est-ce que vous savez en plateau la
différence entre BMX flat BMX parc alors
là non pas du tout alors il s'agit de
faire des figures sur un BMX ça pour les
deux c'est vrai mais il y a quelques
petites différences et notamment pour le
parc qui s'effectue ces sessions
s'effectuent dans un skate park sur des
rampes par exemple BMX parc sera au
programme des Jeux Olympique de Paris
2024 avec des des épreuves place de la
Concorde à Paris ce qui ne sera pas le
cas du du BMX flat qui sera donc non
présent au joio le principe de cette
discipline c'est que les figures
s'exécutent directement euh sur le plat
comme vous le voyez à l'image justement
pas de rampe donc pour ces championnats
de France 3000 spectateurs sont attendus
le prix du billet 10 € pour un jour 15 €
pour les deux jours avec des réductions
possibles si vous êtes licencié de la
Fédération française de cyclisme ou tout
simplement habitant de 50 ans en Yveline
et bien merci beaucoup Grégory canalé
pour toutes ces informations et comme
d'habit si vous aussi vous voyez une
information ou une image près de chez
vous n'hésitez pas à nous la partager
sur les réseaux sociaux en utilisant le
hashtag 78 news
[Musique]
elle s'appelle Aurore edvig et opéli
elles sont yvelinoises elles font de la
recherche et elles sont lauréat du Prix
Jeune Talent l'uréal UNESCO Régine
ralèche et Clara de Frutos sont partis à
leur
rencontre
son ordinateur n'est jamais loin d'elle
edvilleffers cette mansonienne étudiante
en 2e année de thèse à l'Université de
Lille tente de créer une intelligence
artificielle respectueuse de la vie
privée j'essaie de développer des
méthodes qui garantissent de façon
certaine que personne ne peut juste en
interagissant avec lia en posant des
questions reconstruire les données qui
ont été utilisé pour l'entraînement un
cas qui peut notamment s'appliquer au
domaine médical là c'est un exemple ence
artificielle qui est en train
d'apprendre à reconnaître des objets
donc ici par exemple une table et ce
qu'on peut voir c'est que nous sans
avoir accès à la donnée juste en
regardant comment elle apprend c'est
possible de reconstruire l'image donc on
part d'un point au hasard petit à petit
en enlevant le bruit on reconnaît
entièrement la table et à la place de
cette table on pourrait imaginer
n'importe quelle autre image par exemple
dans le domaine médical on pourra avoir
la photo d'un scanner et donc
reconstruire toute l'image du scanner il
compr les coordonnées de la personne qui
peuvent être marqué sur le côté si
edvich s'est attelé à ses recherches
c'est pour lutter contre certaines
dérives de l'intelligence artificielle
gourmand en données et notamment en
données personnelles les algorithmes
peuvent constituer un risque pour les
sociétés et les individus pourvig
recevoir le Prix Jeune Talent L'Oréal
UNESCO dans un milieu masculin est une
marque de reconnaissance et aussi un
levier financier pour lui permettre de
financer ses
recherches c'est à l'Institut Neer
enfant malade dans le 15e arrondissement
de Paris que travaille une deuxième
lauréate ivelinoise Aurore Claude Topin
habitante de poignille Laforêt cette
chercheuse postdoctorante est revenue
des États-Unis il y a 3 ans pour faire
de la recherche dans le domaine de la
cancérologie où elle étudie l'autophagie
donc c'est un processus qui est utilisé
par toutes les cellules dont les
cellules cancéreuses pour pouvoir
produire de l'énergie quand elles en ont
besoin quand elles sont dans des
situations défavorables donc c'est le
cas des cellules cancéreus elles sont en
conditions défavorables elles vont
essayer de utiliser l'autophagie pour
produire de l'énergie survivre jusqu'à
ce que les conditions soit meilleur pour
pouvoir faire des des métastases par
exemple éviter le risque de rechute par
métastase c'est l'objectif d'Aurore mais
si elle a reçu le Prix de la Fondation
l'uréal UNESCO c'est notamment parce
qu'elle utilise un système invitro pour
éviter l'expérimentation animale durant
cette étape clé alors c'est le système
que j'utilise quotidiennement pour
pouvoir mimer INITE trop le transport
des cellules métastatiques dans les
vaisseaux sanguins et ça ça nous permet
d'utiliser moins de de de souris et
d'animaux pour notre projet pour Aurore
le Prix Jeune Talent L'Oréal UNESCO
c'est l'occasion de briser le plafond de
verre dans la recherche mais aussi de
porter une voix pour les étudiants qui
ont comme elle un parcours atypique
c'est OK de faire une filière
technologique et professionnalisante et
c'est même surtout un atout pour pour le
après parce qu'on sait vraiment dans
quel monde on se lance parce que j'ai pu
découvrir le monde de la recherche grâce
à mes stages de BTS cette année le
concours récompense aussi Ophélie
mintosh originaire du chénéo cancour
elle est spécialisée dans
l'astrobiologie et mène des recherches
sur la présence de matière organique sur
la planète Mars auatmos à Saint-Quentin
en Yveline et à
Linaf et c'est d'ailleurs notre invité
ce soir nous reviendrons sur ces
recherches en fin d'émission le mamau
solidaire est de passage dans les
Yvelines cette semaine dans dans le
cadre d'Octobre Rose ce bus itinérant
permet de faciliter l'accès au dépistage
du cancer du sein en proposant
gratuitement une mammographie c'est le
reportage de Julien
Leroi alors l'échographie donc c'est une
technique qui fait appel aux ultçon et
on réalise ce qu'on appelle un balayage
sur l'ensemble de
l'hermeère un camion itinérant pour
aider à sauver des vies depuis le
octobre dernier le mamot solidaire
sillonne l'île-de-fance pour permettre
de Réal is des mammographies contre le
cancer du sein ce mardi le dispositif
était au pied du château de Buc objectif
permettre en priorité au patient sorties
du circuit de dépistage de réaliser leur
examen au plus près de leur domicile la
plupart de femmes hésitent parce que
elles ont peur du résultat c'est
principalement c'est la peur du résultat
et ensuite il paraît que pour certaines
femmes la mammographie elle elle fait
mal donc pourtant c'est un examen qui ne
dure pas plus de de d'une dizaine de
minutes si ce cancer est le plus
fréquent chez la femme le nombre de
dépistage a pourtant diminué de 9,5 % en
10 an détecter suffisamment tôt cette
pathologie peut-être guérie dans 90 %
des cas le mamot solidaire vise à faire
tomber certaines barrières pour
certaines femmes c'est certain que ça
lève des
obstacles soit de matériel de de
proximité de de de déplacement difficil
soit des obstacles psychologiques parce
que pour le dépistage en fait qui
parfois il suffit d'un déclic pour
inciter une patiente à prendre
rendez-vous alors qu'elle aurait hésiter
à passer la porte d'un cabinet de
radiologie de ville en octobre 2022 le
camion francilien a accueilli 265
personnes ce matin-là Séverine a réalisé
sa mammographie suite à la campagne de
communication octobre rose je suis venue
parce que en fait j'ai des antécédents
de personnes qui ont déjà eu aussi des
cancers du sein donc ça m'a mobilisé je
sais l'importance de se faire dépister
très tôt accessible entre 50 et 74 ans
ce service gratuit néccessite une
inscription par téléphone ce mercredi 11
octobre le mamot solidaire s'arrêtera
sur le parking de la mairie de trappe
entre 9h et
18h et toujours dans le cadre d'Octobre
Rose plusieurs communes des ivelines
organisent leur traditionnelle marche ou
cours elles permettent de récolter des
fonds pour soutenir les femmes atteintes
du cancer du sein samedi matin c'était
aiguille en cours qui proposait sa
course solidaire le but était de faire
le maximum de tours de piste en 20
minutes et ils étaient environ 150
motivés à courir pour la bonne cause
c'est pas la première fois qu'on le fait
que je le fais avec ma fille c'est c'est
devenu presqueune tradition de
participer pour une cause qui touche la
femme c'est important d'être là pour
représenter le cancer du sein le sport
aussi c'est un événement qui regroue
plein de monde je pense que c'est
important de pouvoir de pouvoir se
mobiliser surtout pour ce genre de ce
genre de cause ça me semble très
important comme ma fille fait de
l'athlétisme aussi AG en cours c'était
une bonne occasion de venir courir avec
elle allez c'est l'heure à présent de
passer à notre page
[Musique]
culture avis aux passionnés de
littérature la ville royale présente
l'exposition trésor des bibliothèques de
Versailles plusieurs livres rares
parfois même uniques sont à découvrir au
sein de la galerie des Affaires
étrangères
[Musique]
c'est dans la somptueuse galerie des
affairaires étrangères que la ville du
Roi Soleil présente sa nouvelle
exposition les trésors des bibliothèques
de Versailles elle se décline en six
étapes et six thématiques comme la
rareté des œuvres leur esthétique ou
encore leur auteur ça paraît évident de
présenter des trésors dans une
bibliothèque
patrimoniale ce qui est moins évident
c'est de les choisir parce qu'en fait
ici nous avons une histoire qui est
extrêmement riche faite de
décennies de travail sur des collections
qui sont souvent de
très riche provenance au total la
bibliothèque de Versailles dispose de
500000 ouvrages dans cette exposition ce
sont 160 œuvres qui ont été
sélectionnées si vous devez venir voir
quelque chose dans cette exposition je
ne peux que vous conseiller d'aller voir
le sabalom mundi livre
extraordinairement rare le seul
exemplaire que nous conservons l'édition
originale don kishot de Miguel servantes
trésor de la littérature mondiale et
peut-être attardez-vous dans la dernière
salle pour voir des faux trésors mais
qui peuvent se révéler de vrais trésors
autre manuscrit inédit exposé les petits
livres secrets rédigés par Madame de
Maintenon la maîtresse de Louis XIV
l'exposition les trésors des
bibliothèques de Versailles est gratuite
et en accès libre vous pouvez venir la
visiter du mercredi au samedi après-midi
jusqu'au 16
décembre le weekend dernier avait lieu
la 20e édition du Marché International
d'Art Contemporain armané cette année
une quarantaine d'artistes étaient
présents à la ferme du Mané de Montini
le Bretonneux pour exposer et rencontrer
leur public c'est le reportage de
Gabriel Gontier et de Régine
ralche
[Musique]
l'art contemporain à l'honneur le temps
d'un weekend les 7 et 8 octobre dernier
le marché international d'art
contemporain Art Manet ouvrait ses
portes pour une 20e édition organisée
par le lance club Montini un des
intérêts de cette manifestation c'est
bien sûr de découvrir beaucoup
d'œuvres dans des techniques très
différentes mais surtout c'est de venir
découvrir des artistes et ce qui est
intéressant c'est de discuter avec les
artistes ils ont beaucoup de plaisir à
échanger sur leur techniqu sur leur
univers artistique peintre sculpteur
mais aussi photograp une quarantaine
d'artistes étai sélectionnés pour
l'occasion comme cet ancien architecte
venu exposer ses croquis pour la 3è
année je travaille avec une technique
très simple et rapide c'est-à-dire
l'encre exclusivement et l'aquarelle de
techniques qui permettent d'avoir une
spontanéité parfaite sans correction et
premier jet donc je provoque
l'imaginaire je propose et le visiteur
pénètre dans le dessin je suis toujours
surpris j'ai un accueil merveilleux j'ai
les gens qui rêvent alors ceuxl c'est il
pénètrent avec moi dans dans ma bulle
Paris réussit pour lui récompensé par le
Prix du public pour la seconde année
consécutive parfait merci beaucoup
rendez-vous incontournable pour les
amateurs d'art de la région j'adore
l'art je suis toujours impressionnée
parce que les gens arrivent à
de leur mains pour ces 20 ans la
manifestation a connu un vif succès avec
près de 1500 personnes présentes sur
place 30 ans ça se fait au château de
Buc c'était l'effervescence ce weekend
pour la 30e édition du festival de la BD
les fans et les auteurs ont répondu
présent certains sont arrivés dès 4h du
matin pour être sûr d'avoir leur
dédicace c'est le reportage de Mélanie
po s'il n en a bien un seul qui nétait
pas content ce weekend c'était bien
Gargamel à Buc c'était le rendez-vous
annuel des B desfil plus de 8000 d'entre
eux sont venus chasser les dédicaces
chaque année on vient pour faire
dédicacer quelques band dessiné de mon
fils je suis très contente parce que
j'aime bien cette série des profs je
suis venu avec ma fille et mon fils qui
tourne partout parce que parce que c'est
c'est juste génial de toutes ces auteurs
qui sont en train de dessiner de
découvrir comment il dessinent et cetera
et puis après il y a le plaisir de
repartir avec son
et sa dédicace je l'ai rencontré
Monsieur V je suis venu que pour lui
1993 premier festival un rendez-vous
auquel participait déjà westerlin
l'auteur de docteur poche Jeanette
pointu ou encore Tucker je suis venu
déjà dans les premiers puis les années
passé on est pas toujours libre puis il
faut que ça un nouvel album au moins
mais c'est un super festival ça m'étonne
pas qu' il est évolué dans un sens
semblable en 30 éditions le festival a
fédéré de nombreux auteurs plus d'une
4antaines ont accepté de participer
cette année des habitués comme des
petits nouveaux je suis venu à Buc
régulièrement parce que j'habitais à
côté j'habitais à in donc c'était
vraiment très proche j'aimais beaucoup
cette ambiance le château le parc et
cetera j'aime bien les l'équipe qui s'en
occupe parce qu'on se connaît j'aime
beaucoup l'ambiance beaucoup de
monde beaucoup de familles c'est c'est
très
et voilà donc c'est un plaisir de venir
dessiner idé fixes devant autant de gens
sympathiques une trentaine édition sous
le signe de l'émotion pour l'équipe je
rêvais vu les infrastructures de bu et
vu le l'envie aussi de de certains amis
de créer une
petite une petite manifestation du style
de celle que j'ai cité et j'ai donc
écrit à la mairie et deux ou trois
personnes de la mairie ont lu mon
courrier on dit banco en 1993 l'aventure
a été lancée avec une dizaine d'auteurs
au théâtre de Buc l'aventure ne s'est
jamais arrêté aujourd'hui les auteurs
viennent de toute
l'Europe et c'est bientôt l'heure de
l'invité du 78 mais juste avant je vous
propose de jeter un coup d'œil à la
météo de
demain
demain matin nous devrions toujours
avoir un grand soleil sur l'ensemble du
département côté température compté
12°gr à rambouillé 13 à Houdan et 14 à
Versailles et montelajolie durant
l'après-midi le temps reste stable le
ciel sera juste légèrement voilé au
niveau des température elle reste
toujours très haute pour la saison il
fera 25°gr à Mantel jolie Versailles et
rambouillé et 26° à Oudan et demain nous
fêterons la saint-firmain laissez
l'heure maintenant de passer à l'invité
[Musique]
elles sont 35 chercheuses en France à
avoir reçu le Prix Jeune talent pour les
femmes et la science un prix dcerné par
la Fondation L'Oréal et l'UNESCO
l'objectif mettre en avant le travail
des femmes au sein de la filière
scientifique et parmi ces 35 chercheus
livivelinoise Ophélie Mckintosh vous
poursuivez vos recherches à
l'observatoire de Versailles
Saint-Quentin en Yveline et à l'Institut
national italien d'astrophysique alors
sur quoi portent précisément vos
recherches oui euh bonsoir du coup donc
moi je suis astrobiologiste c'est-à-dire
que je m'intéresse à tout ce qui est
origine de la vie et potentiel présence
de vie ailleurs et l'idée c'est que mes
travaux visent à chercher des signatures
de molécules organiques qui sont donc
les bloc de la vie et de trouver des
environnements qui pourraient préserver
ces molécules organiques et aussi aider
à l'interprétation des données puisque
elles sont prises par des Rover oufin
des sondes martiennes sur Mars donc
typiquement le rover Curiosity qui parle
peut-être à certains ça fait 10 ans
enfin plus de 10 ans maintenant qu'il
est sur Mars et donc le l'objectif
global de ces recherches c'est vraiment
de voir si mars à un moment donné de son
histoire a pu avoir développé de la vie
à sa surface et pourquoi est-ce que vous
avez décidé d'étudier sur Mars c'était
la planète la plus facile celle sur
laquelle on a plus de chance de trouver
de la vie alors mars déjà est une des
planètes forcément les plus proches de
la terre donc elle est accessible donc
on peut envoyer des sondes pour
l'explorer et ensuite c'est une planète
qui y a quelques milliards d'années
ressemblait beaucoup à la terre donc
elle avait de l'eau à sa surface elle
avait les sources d'énergies nécessaires
le volcanisme aussi la lumière tout
simplement et on sait maintenant qu'elle
a aussi de donc les molécules organiques
justement donc c'est tous les
ingrédients qui qui aurait pu former de
la vie donc en plus d'être proche elle
avait aussi un peu toutes ces données
nécessaires à à son exploration vous
avez dit il y avait de la présence d'eau
ça ça suffit pas pour le fait qu'il y
ait eu de la vie sur place quels sont
les les critères pour que il y ait de la
vie sur une planète qu'il y ait eu de la
vie sur une planète donc voilà l'eau
c'est un critère essentiel enfin un
solulvant puisqueon pour l'instant on a
juste l'exemple de la terre et on sait
que l'eau est le seul solvant qui est
utilisé par les le vivant mais ça
pourrait être un are solvant c'est des
c'est des recherches qui sont en cours
en cours
d'exploration mais du coup notamment les
molécules organiques sont très
importantes puisque c'est vraiment donc
voilà les briques de la vie la vie est
composé de matière organique donc s'il y
a de la matière organique ça veut pas
dire qu'il y a du vivant mais ça veut
dire qu'elle a pu apparaître donc voilà
ça fait vraiment partie des des gros des
gros ingrédients nécessaires à à à la
vie qui nous intéresse alors avec quel
moyen travaillez-vous pour effectuer vos
recherches vous avez dit vous aviez
étudier le rover Curiosity qui a été
envoyé sur Mars il y a plus de 10 ans
vous êtes aussi allé en Australie en
Italie vous avez fait beaucoup de de
voyage pour pour ces recherches oui
alors du coup enfin moi avant de
travailler en astrobiologie donc pour ma
thèse je faisais de la biologie marine
ensuite donc j'ai décidé de me
reconvertir dans le spatial pour ma
thèse justement euh pour faire ces
études euh donc on a les l'ingénierie
qui nous a permis de mettre des sondes
spatial donc qui sont des enfin ils ont
des laboratoires embarqués qui
permettent de faire les les études
scientifiques pour nous et nous ramener
enfin nous envoyer les données qu'on va
étudier en laboratoire eu et ensuite moi
vraiment en laboratoire je vais euh
reproduire certaines de ces analyses
enfin certains de de
de de
ces bah les données du coup c'est ce
qu'on utilise mais de de enfin par que
des instrumentations qu'on a sur Mars je
vais reproduire en laboratoire pour
essayer de mieux comprendre justement
ces données et savoir comment bah les
interactions entre la la chimie
organique les molécules organiques et
par exemple inorganique comme les sels
ça a été vraiment un gros sujet de ma
thèse vont interagir et donc comprendre
ce qu'on voit en fait après ce qui est
renvoyé par le rover alors grâce à ces
recherches vous avez reçu le Prix
L'Oréal UNESCO ça représente quoi ce
prix pour vous bah déjà c'est un grand
honneur puisque du coup ça ça nous
permet je pense de de s'affirmer dans
ses recherches puisque du coup enfin
voilà il y a un panel de scientifiques
et notamment de l'Académie des sciences
qui
ont nous ont donné enfin un peu ses clés
pour se dire que voilà on fait des
recherches intéressantes euh donc voilà
le gros sujet ça me permet aussi de
parler de ma recherche puisque je
travaille sur un un domaine qui est très
médiatique mais finalement très peu
connu du grand public dans le sens où
l'astrobiologie ça parle pas à tout le
monde on sait pas forcément de quoi on
parle quand on parle de mars qu'est-ce
qu'on fait et puis aussi la dotation qui
a été très généreuse et qui 15000 € dans
le cas des doctorantes donc ce qui est
mon cas et ça va permettre enfin en tout
cas moi je voudrais l'utiliser pour
aller en conférence rencontrer mes pères
euh établir des collaborations justement
donc aller dans d'autres laboratoires
potentiellement internationaux pour
essayer voilà de de faire avancer la
science et et ça ça serait pas possible
sans sans cette dotation est-ce qu'il y
a beaucoup de femmes qui travaillent sur
Mars justement sur sur le sujet de mars
parce que mathil le rappelit tout à
l'heure on a encore un chiffre assez bas
29 % de de femmes parmi les les
chercheurs oui alors donc moi dans les
équipes dans lesquelles je j'ai
travaillé pendant ma thèse j'ai eu
beaucoup de chance ça a été assez c'est
bien réparti hommesfemme mais
effectivement le spatial est connu pour
être un milieu d'homme donc je pense
qu'il y a encore beaucoup d'efforts à
faire avant qu'on arrive à une égalité
hommes-femm vraiment vous sentez qu'il y
a un progrès tout de même depuis
quelques années il y a beaucoup
d'actions qui ont été faites donc
notamment le Prix Jeune talent de
L'Oréal
UNESCO il y a encore beaucoup de
beaucoup de travail du coup au cours de
votre carrière vous vous avez eu des
obstacles justement en tant que femme
chercheuse femmes scientifique alors moi
j'ai eu beaucoup de champ je pense que
je fais partie des exceptions j'ai eu
beaucoup de mentors et de de femmes
autour de moi euh pour justement m'aider
dans ma carrière de Master jusqu même en
post-doctorat maintenant que j'ai
terminé ma thèse euh donc voilà mais je
fais partie des exceptions je pense et
alors jeudi prochain vous allez
justement présenter votre parcours à
1000 jeunes venant de toute
l'île-de-fance au sein de la Cité des
Sciences et de l'Industrie l'objectif
c'est de susciter des vocations chez les
chez les plus jeunes chez les je jeune
filles montrer l'exemple c'est important
pour vous énormément enfin je pense que
j'aurais pas eu la carrière euh une
carrière comme ça si justement les
femmes autour de moi ne m'avaient pas
dit que je pouvais et m'avaient montré
euh que c'était possible donc vraiment
je pense que d'ailleurs c'est le cas de
toutes les candidates quand qu'on a
parlé entre nous on a envie de susciter
justement voilà ces vocation leur parler
leur dire que c'est possible qu'il faut
pas se restreindre à certaines carrières
qui sont encore très connoté masculine
donc oui c'est très important bien merci
beaucoup Ophélie mintosh d'avoir répondu
à nos questions c'est la fin de ce 78
merci pour votre fidélité rendez-vous
demain pour un nouveau 78 avec Grégory
canalé nous serons à l'université des
mairies de l'Ouest parisien parisien je
vous souhaite une belle soirée sur tv78
prenez soin de
[Musique]
vous